awesome no turning back
so uh normally when i when i do these
kinds of talks i really
really like to look at the audience ask
questions
see them nod their heads raise their
arms um and that's hard to do in this
format
because of course we're not all in the
same space but i'm gonna really try to
do some of these same things and so
during the talk you'll see that i'll
stop and i'll ask you questions
and i know that not all of you can
actually talk and answer questions those
of you who can
please feel free to unmute and talk or
respond in the chat pod
and those of you who can't i will post a
url to the forum
where you can actually participate as
well so please
uh please participate i hope that makes
this
next hour or so more fun and more
engaging and keeps you away from
checking your email
and all the other things going on on
your computers
so oh
all right here we go okay so first a
little bit about adobe research
um michael thank you for doing that
really nice introduction but i
i will be honest i am not the person who
started this
growth in 200 people and there were
others there ahead of me
but adobe research is very much a
thriving research lab
um we are actually very close to you at
stanford
we have two offices in one in san jose
one in san francisco
i personally am based in seattle and
then on the east coast we have an
office in cambridge massachusetts and
then in college park
maryland and then abroad we have a
london office
and a bangalore office and we work
across a variety of research areas
including computer graphics computer
vision audio
natural language processing machine
learning and hci
is really at the heart of many of our
projects and so it's really nice to be
here talking to all of you
who are hopefully as interested as i am
in hci
um our main goal at adobe research is to
do cutting edge research and we publish
our work
across some of the top academic venues
like kai and west and
siggraph in addition we've also focused
on taking these ideas and putting them
into products and so here you see
impact on two of our products photoshop
with content aware move
and premiere with 360 video editing and
these projects
these ideas were research papers
originally before they ever made it into
product
now i know that many of you are students
and i
know it's that time of year when you're
trying to figure out what's going on
with the coming year and so i did want
to let you know that we
are looking for interns we had a remote
internship program this year
i think the current plan is to do
another remote internship program next
year but of course
as things develop that may change i also
wanted to tell you
about our fellowship and scholarship
programs they just opened their
applications
and the fellowship program is for phd
students
and the scholarship program is for
master students and undergraduate
students
and i encourage you to check them out
they're both great they include a ten
thousand dollar award
and an opportunity to interview for an
internship
and then i also wanted to uh share that
we are also looking to
fill full-time positions so if you are
graduating definitely check out our
website and apply
and again i'm also happy to answer
questions about adobe research as a
whole or about anything job related
at the end of the talk so
back to our topic so i gave as i said in
the little
introduction and i uh when michael and i
were going back and forth i gave a first
version of this talk
actually a year ago um and at that time
the video uh the title was video as the
core communication tool of the future
and then of course the pandemic happened
and
2020 really like took our world at least
took my world and
turned it upside down and so i thought
well maybe the title is wrong maybe it
should be
video is the core communication tool of
the present because after all
everything i do is over video now
uh but then i thought about it some more
and i said well um
even though i'm actually in front of
video conferencing all day long
the way we actually think about video or
work with video
is really not that different and so i i
kept the title as is
you know and and said well it's still
the core communication tool of the
future and so
now is this moment when i ask you what
do you think
do you think it's do you agree with me
do you agree with this thesis
or do you disagree so those of you who
can't
talk to me oh my gosh look we have a
poll you can vote in the poll so that's
exciting hopefully you all can see this
poll
you can also just turn off your turn on
your audio and talk
or you can use the form to respond
anyone
are you all voting yes maybe
i see nodding you are voting okay we'll
give you some more minutes to vote
in the meanwhile do you want to write
anything in the chat pod or say anything
anyone
we've just crossed 80 votes oh wow
how many people do we have 117.
wow that's amazing thank you all for
coming
okay all right we're slowing down we got
89.
can we hit 90. can i have 90.
um maybe
i could vote i guess let me do that 91
all right here we go i'm going to end
the poll and we'll show ourselves our
results
92 share results
can you all see the poll yes awesome
okay oh my gosh all of you agree but
some
disagree not all of you agree some many
of you agree but some of you definitely
disagree and so i'm curious those of you
who disagree
does anybody want to say more about why
they disagree
i can chime in sure so i want to agree
with you so i'm here to be convinced
but um i disagree in the sense that i
think video has an immediacy to it
in ways that other types of
communication tools don't
that are advantageous as well right such
as texting
such as types of communication that
don't require me to make sure i look
good in order to be in front of you yeah
and i think that these are all things in
which we still need to consider as
a set of communication tools versus just
one main one
yeah that's a great
um that's a great answer when i um
when the um
when the um announcement for this talk
actually
went out this week i got a couple of
emails from from folks who said oh my
gosh i'm so excited about this and one
of them was actually marty hurst
who's a professor at uc berkeley and she
was like i
you know i really feel like there's a
you know there's this
trend away from text and towards video
kind of that's her feeling and so she
was excited to hear about this talk
and i but like you actually i would say
that
um the pandemic world has made me do a
lot more writing
than i ever did before so i agree with
you
and that it's not really an either or
like it's not just going to be video
it's not just going to be text i think
that there is absolutely
a place for all different kinds of
communication i just think that
um video as a as a communication tool
is a place where we see i think there is
a gap
and so that's part of why i i make this
claim
so so with that let's let's jump in
so this talk was inspired by research
that i learned about
about a year and a half ago and it was
done by one of our research teams at
adobe
and they had spent several months
visiting k-12 classrooms
across the united states learning about
the technology the students were
engaging with
in the classroom at that time now
remember this is
a year and a half ago so pre-pandemic
time right the world is probably
different and it would be really
interesting to do this research again
but at that time
here's what the look the world looked
like so they they talked to about 50
teachers administrators and students and
visited a mix of public and private
schools
and also looked at um some of the
quantitative research that had been done
in this space really trying to
understand what are the technology
trends
in schools and what i learned that day
when i was
watching this report being presented is
that in
in schools at that time there were two
types of tools
there were special project tools and
core communication tools
as you might imagine special project
tools are tools that are being used
for projects things like making posters
with images videos
telling a story interactive reports
small books
and the tools that students use really
varied a lot across teachers
there was no one tool that each
each teacher encouraged their students
to use
in contrast core communication tools
were widely used across just about every
teacher
that the research team spoke with and
some teachers mentioned that
they would actually scaffold use of
these tools so they would introduce
different parts of them
over time and really you know wanted the
students to learn
how to do this how to use these tools
some of them
started teaching them as early as
kindergarten and really these teachers
felt the familiarity with with these
tools is an important part of computer
literacy
so as i sat there listening to this
report the question i asked myself
was um what are the core communication
tools of the future
right so for today you can based on the
icons you can guess these core
communication tools are things like
powerpoint
things like documents right um but i
asked myself well
um what are the tools that every student
will need to know to be successful in
life
in the future and of course i put my
adobe hat on right i work at adobe not
at
microsoft or google i ask myself you
know adobe's tools
fall on this special project side like
are there any of adobe's tools that ever
will ever be core communication tools
that will be
especially in the space of creative uh
work will they ever be um
core communication tools and so of
course given the title of this talk
i'm sure you will not be surprised that
i zeroed it on video
um largely because i see their um this
group huge growth in video communication
and yet like a huge gap in how we use
video
and how we work with video so let's look
at some examples
so i showed you some information about
adobe research earlier in the talk and i
flashed some numbers
i even maybe showed you some urls and
before maybe you had a chance to really
see any of this information
write it down take a screenshot i moved
on
and you know this happens all the time
it happens to me all the time i'm
listening to a talk something something
happens and by the time i write it
where i sit down and write it down it's
too late and so maybe
maybe you actually can the only way you
can get access to this information is to
you know look at a recording right
michael and catherine are recording this
talk
i'm sure you'll get the link and so here
is a recording of a of a practice i gave
to myself um yesterday and so now maybe
you know you have this recording and you
want to find that part
where you have the numbers and so you're
jumping around
and it's really hard to figure out where
is it out there you know maybe i missed
an internship there is the url
right so figuring out how to get
information from videos
very hard
something connected to this happened to
me i
missed a keynote at last year's kai
conference i couldn't see it
live but my colleagues saw it and they
said mira this is a really really good
talk
there's some really great insights in
there you have to watch it
so i said awesome okay i will watch it
um but then of course i didn't have an
hour to watch the talk
and i didn't have any clue how to get to
the parts that my colleagues thought i
should watch
i also knew there was a back channel
there's always a back channel
but i had no way to layer on that
information
and use it as a way to look through that
video
maybe today there is a back channel
maybe all of you are talking
and maybe that means you know if you're
talking a lot maybe that means that my
talk
is really boring or maybe you really
agree or disagree
with something i'm saying either way i'd
like to know about it that way i can
adjust
and hopefully make this as good as
possible for you
so as i thought about video and what a
core communication tool for video
would look like i created a framework to
help me think about
video tasks and so let's walk through it
so
one axis of this framework is are you
trying to create video
are you consuming video so what are you
doing with video
another one is is this an interactive
task or a passive task right so
sitting down and watching tv or watching
a movie that's a passive task
actually trying to like pick browse a
video and quickly find some information
that's interactive another axis is this
an iterative task
or a one-time task right so um
do you do this over and over with the
same video or just one time
individual or collaborative are you
doing this with others
or by yourself and then if you are doing
it with others is the synchronous or
asynchronous
so let's go through some examples of of
how to apply the framework
so you are all attending this talk for
you this is the consumption task
for some of you it's totally passive
you're just listening
for others it is interactive maybe
you're jotting things down
maybe you're even you know interacting
with me with the questions
it is a one-time experience i don't
think i'll come back and do it again
um it is collaborative we're doing this
together you're doing this with others
and it is very much synchronous
now let's say you're actually watching a
recording of this talk
for you this would be again a
consumption experience
it may be again totally passive or you
may be pausing and playing at times
it may be a multiple experience you know
when we're watching
videos you may come back to this over
and over again maybe you watch it once
you come back for something else
um it's something that you're going to
do likely by yourself i mean some people
are doing these things
more collaboratively these days but in
general it's individual
um and so you know it's therefore
individual
now let's look at me making this talk so
i
made this talk i am not creating a video
however i did work with video to put
in this talk right so i had to consume a
bunch of videos
to put into my talk and then i had to
trim them
and clip out parts and remove audio and
so i had to deal with
video you know so it's kind of somewhat
video creation
very much interactive very much
iterative
most of it i did on my own but i also
got feedback from others so i got
feedback from my team
and some of that feedback i got live
through
um you know a meeting kind of like this
but some of it i also got over email
so i had some asynchronous feedback
i'll give you one more example it's kind
of yet another
point in the space so this is my friend
debbie she
um has a business um
selling spices actually but she also
part of her business is about
virtual cooking classes and so if you um
subscribe to her class you will get a
box and then
on the day of the cooking class you join
her live cooking experience over video
conferencing so very much like
what we're doing right now and so she
has a small number
of people in their own kitchens cooking
with her
simultaneously and then she's also
broadcasting kind of to the public
and the public is not cooking with her
they're just watching what's going on
right so i attended one of her
virtual cooking classes for me this was
really a video consumption experience
right i i was not i was i was cooking i
was not
editing video um it was
uh very passive for some people right
the people who
are not like interacting and trying to
cook together and asking questions
they're just watching much like
maybe you would watch a cooking show at
home on tv
uh but for those who are part of the
live cooking class it was very
interactive
it was again a one-time experience um
it was very much collaborative and
synchronous
so i hope these examples convince you
that touching video
is part of almost everything we do today
yet our interfaces for viewing and
working with video remain
the same the interface is the same no
matter what i do
i could be watching a movie or i could
be trying to fix my sync
and this is really where i think we need
to focus as an hci community is to make
using video easier we really need to
invent
new ways to work with video
good news is that the computer vision
and audio communities
um have really made a lot of progress in
helping us
understand what's in video or helping
machines understand what's in video
so machines now can see people and
objects
they can understand what's happening
what motion
uh what scenes are what geometry and we
can take
the sounds and if it's speech transcribe
that into
words and also understand where there
are different
kinds of sounds happening in a video and
some of the early work and taking
advantage of these capabilities
starts with one of stanford's own
menesha manish chagruela manisha i saw
you are in the audience is
excited to have you here um venetian his
students were among the first to show
how transcripts can make video and audio
editing much easier
and today we even have commercial tools
tools like dscript
that enable a new way to edit video
that's much easier than what was
possible before
so what does all of this video
understanding technology mean for
interfaces
so this is the next interactive part
what do you all think
what should video interfaces be in the
21st century
you all can fill out the form you can
type things in the chat um
so to get you all thinking
you know maybe one thing all videos
should have
in the 21st century the table of
contents so that i don't have to do this
crazies
you know hunting and pecking on the
timeline and we're already seeing that
in youtube so for any
not for any youtube author but for many
youtube authors if you write a table of
contents in the description
they'll actually create an interface
that's easier to to
to find those sections another idea
maybe
all videos should be translatable
into documents and so here you see some
work from valentina shin
who is that adobe who's taken videos
from khan academy videos
khan academy style lectures and turns
them into documents so it's much easier
to scan and learn from them so what do
you all think
what should video interfaces be what
should we
imagine them to be while the panelists
are queuing up we have a few
people who've responded to the form i'll
just read out what they said
uh one says i'm imagining that vr and ar
or something distinct from video
so maybe if they become big that won't
count as video uh someone else said
incorporate ctrl f for video to make it
easier to skip through a video and find
things
faster like adobe's few shot audio
detection project a third person said
searchable text transcripts
a fourth person said the ability to
bookmark or make notes at different
parts of a video
uh and now i've got a fifth that says
less clicking more shortcuts
that sounds like well it sounds
fantastic and yes
i mean ctrl f you can already do this
actually in some ways searchable
transcripts is already available
so on on youtube i don't know if all of
you know but you can turn on transcripts
and you can search i mean it's not
available for everything but for many
videos it is and you can just use
command
f in your um
in your browser but it's not always
enough i think one thing that's
interesting about search that i found
myself is that
yes if i'm looking for something very
specific like a word somebody is saying
it can be effective
but if i want to know what this video is
about and the right section to go to
it words are not going to be enough and
so but i agree with you
without a lot of these ideas being able
to search videos
in the same way that we search documents
is definitely
something we'd love to see the the
comment about vr and air is also really
interesting
um and i i can't remember exactly what
the comment was i think
it is interesting to think about just
what video will
be or look like in a vr or ar
environment um
i know that we've there is some work at
adobe on using tutorials
in vr environments so if you are for
example learning how to paint
how do you make it make use of others
who
have shared their way of painting how do
you take those videos and import them in
vr and ar environments
i think there you're even more
impoverished right so you don't have a
mouse
you have these controllers and so being
able to browse these videos
in a way that is easy is actually even
more important
so but lots certainly we expect to see
lots and lots of
changes to our interfaces as we uh
explore some of these
different modalities
um are there any more comments michael
or should we go ahead
oh yeah we got more um let's see
the ability to bookmark or make notes at
different parts of a video another
person says less clicking more shortcuts
another person says interactive and
allowing for experimentation with
alternative
alternate realities especially in
education videos like deep fakes but not
as
morally questionable uh another person
says auto suggesting related or helpful
external videos for each section
uh someone else said there should be
interfaces like you mentioned right now
there's a single interface for different
contexts or modes of consumption
i think there should be different domain
specific interfaces based on the context
um another one says for verbal or oral
communication in videos controls
related to the words per minute of this
feature speaker rather than one one x or
one point five x or two x speed
so that it's always catered to your
speaking pace preferences
oh i love that that would be so cool i i
have to say i
watch a lot of video recordings these
days of meetings that i can't attend or
i've missed
and i never watch them at 1x it's just
torture
um but uh you're right like some people
i can listen to it to us
and then others are speaking way too
quickly and so then i have to
to bring it down so yeah that would be
really cool that's a great idea
um so some of these great ideas i i love
the ideas of bookmarks
um i think you some of this is already
possible too because i i do get links
sometimes that jump me directly to
specific parts and videos so
i think some of this is already coming
to fruition which is which is exciting
to see
so let's take a look at um a few
examples i think all of you are thinking
of great ideas i just want to show you
four example systems
that really rethink how we create and
consume video
and i just want to say that these are
four points in the space
please don't think of this as an
exhaustive list there is a lot of
fantastic work
that i'm sure some of you working on
this are here in the audience
so um so this is another interactive
part i have four systems that i want to
talk about today and you all get to vote
on which one we talk about first so um
i think michael has a poll ready for you
and so you get to vote
uh on one of the systems
and so we'll give you a few minutes i
know you don't really know what these
systems are so it's not really
fair but um some of you do and and the
rest of you i guess can vote
based on your favorite name favorite
title
word about 60 votes so far all right
it's pretty neck and neck actually yeah
so we will um we'll do this
um after each system so you will get to
vote again
uh for two more times i'm gonna have to
update my hole then
i don't know if you can just rerun it
michael but anyways we can try it
i'll i'll play with it all right we got
82 i think
i'm calling it here all right
this oh 83
this is extremely close
okay i think decision bias wins the day
[Laughter]
by two votes i'll note i actually know
by one vote it'd be
restream by one vote
fantastic i mean we uh we are in a
season of close elections so there you
go
too soon too soon i know sorry i should
i shouldn't uh
anyway let's not think about that um all
right i'm gonna go ahead and close this
so let's talk about b script so b script
so this uh system so you know on that
slide with
with all the different cool things um
happening in the in the world
one of the things i pointed out was
transcript and so what b script does is
it shows how we can use
transcripts to make editing a video
easier and specifically it focuses on
b-roll video editing so
um right there's a rising trend in
online videos for vlogging of course
i'm guessing you guys know this this is
a multi-billion dollar business on
youtube with millions of subscribers
and these videos are often a vlogger so
like this guy
talking about some kind of topic and so
it's often like a headshot
of him or her but there's cutaways
to some kind of effect and this type of
cutaway is what we call
b-roll and so the b-script system um
assists users with this last part to
find and insert b-roll
that goes into making this video about
this specific topic
and so this is what the b-script
interface looks like it has a video
preview
and a timeline transcript view which
supports navigation by clicking
and a search panel for actual b-roll
footage
which is integrated with the interface
so users can double-click
on a word in the transcript and then
search for relevant b-roll footage
now the core of the interface is
actually a recommendation system
so it analyzes the transcripts text and
makes recommendations for good locations
for where to insert the b-roll
and what the content of that b-roll
should be so here the green light
the green highlights indicate the
recommended b-roll location
and then the keywords on the right show
the actual query you could use to find
relevant content
and so all you have to do as a user is
click on that query
and then you see a list of potential
b-roll that you can add to your video
so i one thing before i show you the
results
note that there is no like timeline
there is no in and out points
you're really just using the transcript
as a way to decide where to add
additional footage and of course you
know this is one specific interface it's
not going to be general purpose for
everything but it is an example of what
we can do
if we really narrow down our use case
and so here are some examples on the
left and on the right of
kind of two of the same video one with
b-roll and one without
and so kind of quick this is like a
quick overview of what b script is but
you know in this particular case we see
the transcript based interface is
more efficient and as easy as a
timeline-based interface
and these recommendations around what
kind of content and how to get good
content are really really helpful
and so if we try to take the system and
throw it into our framework that one
we discussed earlier you know in b
script
you are creating video so it's really a
creation task
however you're consuming b-roll footage
is part of it right you can
have to consume all these examples to
figure out which ones to fit where
and it is and the system is really
designed to help you consume
content more quickly right you don't
have to watch all the b-roll
is helping you find both where to put it
and
what good videos could be um it is an
interactive experience of course it's
iterative
and you do it on your own in this
particular example
okay so um what should we talk about
next
oriole mixty or restream michael are you
able to do the
poll again
perfect so um be script is an option
uh but i promise you we will not talk
about it again
so if you vote for it um i'm sorry your
vote will be wasted
so we already have uh some third-party
votes for beefscript
so please pick one of the others
all right we're at 75
it's tied right now so we need
at least one more person to vote
i am not voting so um because that would
be cheating
we are currently deadlocked people keep
voting for the one that's not in the tie
position okay
five seconds last chance
um well here we go
we had uh 28 votes
restream by one and then one ahead of
mixed t
wow okay so let me
so thank you all for voting this is cool
let's jump ahead
to restream okay i'm just going to note
that those
b script voters could have swung the
election
[Laughter]
um all right so let's talk about
restream so this was work
um done at a derby at the time ailee
frazier who is now at adobe she was a
phd student at
ucsd and this is really
um looking at creative live streams so
um so far so i just kind of shifting
gears a little bit in b script we talked
a lot about creation right we're
creating videos
this is really all about consumption so
for the past several years um we've been
studying creative live streaming and
there's a growing interest
in general and creative live streaming
at adobe because there is a
growing community of artists who are
streaming live this was true even before
the pandemic but of course
with the pandemic it's really kind of
increased significantly
and so here is an example of such a
stream and in general artists
are now broadcasting as they work on
these creative projects
and they do this with multiple goals in
mind some are teaching and trying to
share
their practice some are just working
actually without talking very much
and then others use this um platform to
socialize with other artists so
note that artists are often freelancers
and they
may be at home working by themselves and
so getting connected to others
um through a stream is a way to build a
community
and what's interesting about live
streams is that they unlike tutorials
um show an unedited process behind the
creative work
so it's not really a step-by-step
tutorial you see
everything you see the mistakes the
decisions
anything that happens along the way
and so we often think about live streams
as something that people consume live
but many of these platforms also archive
these videos
and then people can come back to them
and watch them
which is nice because of course not all
of us can be there
at the same time as each other and
especially when you have a
you know artists from all over the world
streaming in their own
time zones it's not possible for uh each
of us to
catch up with the artists we love so
and while these videos are pretty
amazing and they have this like
wealth of knowledge it's pretty
challenging to
browse them right you can imagine many
of these are three four hours long
and it's just really hard to make sense
of which parts to watch
and so in this work we really focused on
this idea of how do we take these
creative live stream archives
you know these are videos that are quite
long how do we make it easier to watch
and navigate them
one way to do that is with a table of
contents that divides
um the content into sections and
many people do manually make these as i
said youtube now
um supports actually parsing of these
descriptions
and then many websites like this is
skillshare actually
um add that as part of the authoring
interface as part of the video sharing
interface directly
and so as part of this work we spoke
with streamers and viewers about the
value of having such a table of contents
and find
found that for streamers um they do see
a value
in having this table of contents but
they don't have the time to make it
so they've sat down they've just
streamed for multiple hours the last
thing they want to do is actually do
anything for that content
and for viewers it was really useful to
see
a table of contents as an overview and
get a quick understanding of what
happened
however we also found that viewers of
the same video
really differed in what they wanted from
a table of contents and that there was
no
right way for us to segment creative
live streams
so some were really interested in
specific techniques
others really wanted to know kind of the
overall experience
and so it the other part of this is that
these streams don't often have as
obvious of a structure as tutorials
and so it makes it harder to figure out
what table of contents
to create but on the other hand since
there are many different possible
segmentations
many different possible table of
contents perhaps
any table of content is better table of
contents is better than nothing
and so um to do this we put together an
approach and it's a
user in the loop approach so the system
first automatically segments the live
stream
into sections and then the streamer uses
this
automatic segmentation and adds titles
and adjusts any sections so sometimes
there might be two um smaller sections
that really should be one and so the
streamer can put them together
and this allows the streamer to really
maintain agency over their content
how does this work um we have a
segmentation algorithm that takes
um that can take advantage of well in
general the way you would want to do
this
is you would want to look at both what's
happening visually
you would want to look at what the audio
is like what is the streamer saying
uh what's happening in the software you
know if you have access to that or
you're able to extract that from the
video
what is what are the tools someone's
using and then of course you have the
chat
so you can take all this information and
try to
create a table of contents in this
particular work
um we used only the narration and the
software actions
in subsequent work we've looked at how
to take advantage of the visual
information as well and so the algorithm
essentially identifies
candidate boundaries based on the
software actions and the narration
identifies intro and outro because they
look quite different than the middles
and then combines the remaining
intervals into
sections and to determine what these
sections should be we use
um a scoring function that combines four
heuristics
uh one of them is around duration we
prioritized in this
particular project that sections should
be between 1 and 10 minutes long
based on our conversations with
streamers
we also based on prior works found that
um
certain commands indicate the start and
end of a subtask
also we found that certain um tasks the
they use streamers use the same tools in
certain tasks
so they group certain tools um as
they're working on a specific task
and then last we looked at the
transcript semantics and looked for
words like start
and next and done and that's all because
those often also
indicate transitions
so to evaluate the algorithm's output
with streamers
we built a prototype interface and had
them actually use it and evaluate both
the um the sections that this
algorithm created and then also labeled
them
and so this is an example of what it
looks like after someone has labeled it
and we also had the fortune of being
able to work with the behance team which
is
adobe's creative social network and a
version of this algorithm is actually
deployed now on the website and so if
you go to the behance website
you'll see that some of the live streams
have chapters
uh where that are segmented
and give an overview
and so some of the takeaways from
restream are that streamers really like
the automatically created sections
and the algorithm definitely performed
better on some streams than others
instructional streams where there is a
linear structure and you go
from one section to the next to the next
are much easier to segment in a
meaningful way
than um streams where there's a lot of
back and forth and the streamer isn't
quite sure
what process they're going to follow so
that type of exploration is harder to
discover
with the current approach that we've
been uh trying
and so that's definitely an interesting
space for future work
and so if we look at the um how restream
fits into the framework
it is definitely a consumption interface
it is interactive it's something they
can use over and over or just one time
you know it depends on your consumption
and then again it's something that you
use on your own
all right so we have one last poll
um i think between oriole and mixty
which system would you guys like to talk
about next
michael do you want do you want to show
them the poll okay
so my question is shouldn't your tools
allow us to just watch this in any order
depending on which tool we wanted to
hear about oh
i mean yes if this was a video um that
was pre-recorded but you guys get me
live so i can't talk about all of them
at the same time
you're basically about at the equivalent
of a random access talk
the closest i've ever seen uh we got 77
votes out of 126 people here
let's see if we can hit 80. all right we
got 80.
um i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna do the
network thing of calling this
this vote uh because it's clear
i love it oh wow big win
for mixty i mean compared to the last um
the last round of
this is why ranked choice voting is
valuable here we go
okay all right let me
jump to mixtee
okay so let's kind of before i jump into
mixty to recap so we have b script which
shows you how to use
or shows how we could use transcripts
then we had
restream which is really all about
making use of tool commands
and transcripts and trying to kind of
you know give you a
better consumption experience for these
live streams by giving you a table of
contents
what mixtee is trying to do is looking
is really trying to kind of
look at the space between well he's
trying to address
the situations where a video on its own
is just not enough
and so the work this is work from quite
probably the oldest of the works that
i've shown you here is from wisc 2012
collaboration with peggy chi who is now
at google
and bjorn hartmann um from uc berkeley
and really the the question we had at
the time
was there are lots of benefits to static
video
to static tutorials and there are lots
of benefits to videos
how might we combine these two videos
at least how might we combine these two
formats
while there are benefits to static and
there are benefits to video there are
also drawbacks
and so we were trying to do is kind of
take the best of both worlds
and come up with something in between to
be more concrete static tutorials are
really easy for scanning right you can
quickly scroll down that page and say
hey
oh this is exactly the tutorial i want
this is the piece that is going to help
me do that one thing
video and contrast really helps you with
the tasks that require you to see
how something is done over time so if
you want to learn a specific painting
technique
it's hard to do that in a static
tutorial you really need to see it in
video form and so
the question was how do we make you know
how do we take the advantages how do we
take
the benefits of both so
um and so the approach was really to
take
a system a user demonstration system is
to make this
and to create these mixed media
tutorials
so a mixed media tutorial is something
you see here in this video this is
essentially
a static tutorial but each picture
is also a video so here you see that i
clicked on that picture and then it
became a video and i can see more
details
of how this particular drawing is done
and there are different versions of the
video you can see the entire screencast
or particularly you know a specific part
of crop version
or you can see kind of the whole frame
for context
and then see a zoomed version of it
which highlights the parts that the user
actually touched in the interface and so
the idea of these mixed media tutorials
was really to take
um to let you scan the way you would a
static tutorial
but then in those parts where you wanted
more detail
you could you could reference the video
and the system the mixty system was
really trying to
do this as automatically as possible
right so
um creating video tutorials is really
easy you just turn on the camera
and start performing what if creating
these types of mixed media tutorials
was just as easy and so that's that's
what the system is really about
and so we showed that these mixed media
tutorials are in fact better than video
or static tutorials alone
and this details on demand approach
really allows the users to quickly jump
to the point of interest and so again
mixture was focused on consumption it
was interactive
interactive experience because you can
scan and
jump ahead it's something again you
could do one time
or iteratively depending on who you are
and again individual experience
all right so next let's jump to oriole
um okay
so oriole is a system built by
several researchers at a derby and an
intern who joined us back in 2018 and
this was work that was published at kai
2019 and the idea of oriole was really
to look at how we might take advantage
of some of
some of the human pose understanding
that's possible today
so um let's jump in so
in the work in this in this research the
goal is really to make it much easier to
create videos like this one
so here we have hans rosling he's
talking about the relationship between
lives
and income and to create this video hans
rosling really
couldn't do it himself right he had to
hire a production team and spend many
hours working
and so the goal of the oreo project was
to make this type of authoring much
easier by allowing people to create
mappings between
the human pose and animated graphics
and so here's the type of video one can
create with oriole this is to keep
the first author and and former intern
who worked with uh with us on this and
he's telling us about what it's like
to live in seattle um especially in
november
and so um so to create this experience
all one has to do
is draw the graphics so in this case the
umbrella
and to connect it to the skeleton
representing the human pose
or motion and so here are some of the
stories that people were able to create
with oriole
so this is claire she's telling you
about how to boil eggs
and here is an astronomer talking about
his research
and here is an interior decorator who's
showing how to decorate a room
and how to i guess in this case clean
your windows
so what the oriole system shows is that
you can
um use um so human body abstraction so
being able to connect how the body moves
to motion graphics is useful and there's
this really rich space of opportunities
for this live action videos
and object aware sketching interfaces i
think especially
um these days as as video understanding
and pose tracking gets better and better
i think well it's really exciting to see
these kinds of interfaces
where you don't need to do programming
to really offer these types of very rich
experiences
and as far as how oreo fits into the
framework this is a very classic
creative tool it's very much focused on
creation
um it's interactive iterative and done
on your own
and so let's jump ahead
to
the end putting it all together
so um we saw four different systems
hopefully the order was not too
distracting for you and all kind of fits
together in your brains
i think what's what's interesting to
look at is that there has been
a lot of interesting research across the
spectrum both for consumption and for
creation of course a lot of is
interactive which
which is great although you might want
to ask well what would a different
passive interface look like
right um much of it is focused on
iterative experiences
i think the the thing that jumps out to
me is that
there hasn't been as much work around
collaboration and video
um there's some collaborative video
authoring
but really collaborative video
consumption um i haven't seen as much
research in that space i know there are
these watching parties that are
happening more and more and so there's
but i think you know as we think about
one way we could use this framework is
to think about what are opportunities
for future research and where
where are there gaps in the space where
new cool things are
useful and so to conclude i hope i've
convinced you
that we need to be thinking more about
video and how to make it easier to deal
with video
and as hci researchers it's really our
responsibility to make it easier for
everyone
to communicate with video i started this
talk with a little bit about what's
happening in schools or at least was
happening in schools
before the pandemic um and it's a good
you know it's good to check in with how
things are there now
um and while this isn't you know the
universal experience i can tell you my
experience
um this is my son um he's seven
he's in second grade he doesn't use any
of the tools
that i showed you in the previous slides
he uses um
zoom and schoology and seesaw
and he talks to his class over video and
he now knows how to unmute and mute
himself how to change his background how
to be silly in the chat
he records videos of his artwork he
shares it with his teacher and his
classmates
um he does you know almost all his
assignments online
and he watches youtube videos that were
created by his teachers
and until his this spring i mean his
teacher had never
ever taught online but now
she has to she doesn't have a choice
so thank you so much i really appreciate
your time today
i'm happy to take your questions i think
we have still a few minutes
thank you mira excellent
um so panelists go ahead and unmute
yourselves
if you want to ask questions um you know
you can go ahead and
stop your video if you or you stop
sharing your screen if you want to see
us
um that's great and for all the
attendees all approximately of 100 of
you who are not panelists
uh i'm uh there i'll send out a link
that is for
where you can submit your questions
there we go
uh so we have a couple minutes for
questions um
we have some in in the queue already but
i would like to invite a panelist if
they want to start
all right well when we got in the um in
the queue already
uh was a question to ask whether the uh
needs when you looked at the the needs
of viewers of streamers with large
audiences
whether those differ from viewers of
smaller streamers i mean
i think uh absolutely so
also when you say larger versus smaller
there's you know i would ask you what do
you mean by a larger versus smaller
because
there are streams with thousands of
viewers and then they're
you know there's so so that would be
kind of one way to divide it up but i
think
if you look at really really large
streams i mean i uh
you know there is this problem with
you know the audience being able to
communicate period right so communicate
with each other
communicate with the streamer right the
chat is is often just like scrolling off
the page and it's hard to consume it at
all right and there has been research on
trying to make that
more consumable by making smaller groups
for example we're trying to summarize
what's going on in the chat
so for large streams very different
problems
i think the smaller um the smaller
streams
you know again it really depends on what
um what kind of stream it is
if the people know each other so
sometimes these streams are very
especially in the creative community
very tight-knit groups
so they all know each other and so when
somebody joins a stream
um the artist will often be like oh hi
how are you what's going on right
so you end up with these um personal
conversations which maybe are not that
interesting
to everyone right so in a in a smaller
stream you might want to
be able to navigate those you know those
types of
conversations flag though so you can
just kind of skip over them maybe if
you're watching a recording or maybe
even have something
live that's like oh unmute this i'm
going to mute this now unmute it for me
automatically whenever they stop
chit chatting and actually get back to
like talking about the art
right so you can imagine uh definitely
different types of tools for these
different types of streams
we have another question that i think
ties into this it was asking
do you think that these kinds of tools
which seem really useful for a specific
kind of creation might result in a
splintered experience for video
consumers who have to learn a bunch of
different interfaces
um i guess i'm i don't know that i
understand the question exactly
can you either say it again or i can try
army
i think i think that the question is
essentially asking
if we create all of these special
purpose tools for specific
contexts um are we going to be
splintering the
sort of user experience in a way where
they when no one knows which tool to go
to when or
or everyone winds up with the sort of
least lowest common denominator
so i think this is in the context of
like authoring is this in the context of
like authoring interfaces so if i'm
authoring
video lectures versus authoring um
you know uh i don't know a uh
performance art you know maybe
you'd have different types of tools i
guess my
my i don't i still don't quite feel like
i understand the question very well but
um i guess i'll say on the creation side
um
you know i think there is this question
of do you want to have a very
task specific interface or do you want
to have a general purpose interface
um ideally you have a task specific
interface then
can adapt itself into something that's
more general purpose
so that you know if you wanted to do
more things that are not just the task
specific thing you can
move in that direction but there's of
course challenge in doing kind of any
kind of adaptation
i think there is a challenge that maybe
is what this question is about around
like if i
use one interface that's very different
than yours then how can you learn from
my experience
using it right what we see a lot on
youtube today around learning content is
that
um you know how-to videos are like one
of the most common
um type of learning content on youtube
and so
if i teach you how to use photoshop with
my version of photoshop but your
photoshop looks totally different then
you can't really make use of it
of my video right so i do think that is
one problem with having highly
customized interfaces is that it becomes
harder
to for others to teach each other and so
i think there we would need
new um new tools that let you adapt
right like you i'd love to see
something that can take your video with
your version and kind of show me
what that means in my version uh but we
don't we don't have that today
all right panelists questions
yeah um i have just a follow-up so i'm
still in the process of being convinced
and i think it's probably because you're
talking to a sociologist and so not
necessarily a
technical person in the way hci is no
and so you end with this sort of
um you know the scenario of your um
of your your children going to school
online but if you talk to most educators
today especially
of younger children they're saying that
online video education is failing us
right and i also think you have
a very great case right now like this
fantastic natural experiment and
we are forced to be on video and i think
there's moments where you can see both
at play for example the chat
we have going on there is a chat that
goes on because people are having these
private conversations
offline in a way that you couldn't do in
real life
and i guess i'm just sort of putting it
out there that i think there's still a
lot of avenue for exploration
um and other ways in which you can
really think about the cl the
intersections of all these different
ways of communicating and to make them
work i'm not saying video is not the way
to go um
you know in our own field we've been
really thinking about how video can be
used to
do qualitative interviewing and
qualitative research for example
and i think a sort of um it opens up
avenues but it's also not a replacement
for old ones right
ethnography over video is not the same
as going into a space and learning about
a space
so those are sort of some thoughts yeah
and and
i think thank you for all those points i
think they're great
and i can i can tell you that absolutely
it is not as good for my seven-year-old
school is not as good um that is um that
is true
um and it is and i'm and you know it's
not going to be the only method and i
really hope
that video in 10 years is really
different than video today right i mean
um there are you said michael like over
100 people here
we are not having a conversation with
over 100 people right some people are
quiet and some are talking some don't
want to be visible and some are
and those of you who have been on video
all day are probably exhausted and like
can't wait
to turn this off right so so absolutely
there
are um huge huge um
interesting questions and opportunities
as i said
in my own work i've actually started
doing a lot of
text a lot of writing a lot of
asynchronous communication because
um because people are on different
schedules and so we can't actually get
even at this
you know in the same video room uh it's
just not possible so
i agree with you there's lots of
opportunity for interesting new
modalities
and video i think will be a part of it
for sure